if this is me I don't want it anymore it
doesn't make me happy
hi my name is Stanley hi I'm Michelle
and today we are trying to guess which
of the burgers is vegan I am definitely
a meat lover especially when it comes to
burgers I don't think I could ever
prefer like a vegan burger to like a
meat burger I've always eaten meat I
love me vegan food is good too I'm a
meat eater honestly like if I don't eat
meat at least once a day I feel weird
I've cried before because there wasn't
enough protein at home when it comes to
like meat substitutes I always find I
was really weird like faint but like the
impossible burger it's just like
apparently it like bleeds and that's
like their big like marketing thing I
don't know I would prefer if you just
pretend it's its own thing
I feel like our chances of guessing
which one isn't meat is are like pretty
high vegan meat or like meat substitutes
have a special taste I feel like I think
it'll be tough usually I think I could
tell if a patty is a meat patty or not
if it's juicy but if it's combined with
all these things the lettuce potato the
condiments and everything I feel like
it's a lot easier to get away with like
being vegan you know some fast food or
frozen burgers are also questionably
meat as it is like they taste pretty
strange sometimes true true
all right blindfold do I look good yeah
you look great thank you
this is like some Jedi training up here
it is so what is this is like a quarter
of a burger now it smells good oh oh
it's this it's this guy
oh I'm laughing cuz all I can feel is
bread yeah
whatever this is this is not great oh I
know this smell taste like college I
feel like this is a taste that some
people know too well this is still beef
though you know what I yeah I agree I
think this is a still a meat patty which
is not a very good room it has a really
like meaty flavor and we don't you on it
the texture still seems like me even
though it's like super thin it's like a
stick is a slice of cheese I'm like
tempted to eat all of it so that makes
me feel like it's probably beef nothing
about this gives me a vegan vibes it's
overcooked it's flavorless but it's just
still beef yeah okay
second ones down up this one's thicker
ah eating when you're blindfolded is so
hard there's a lot of stuff on this this
is a vegetable I can feel it already
there's this chicken I think this is
still a meat patty but I think it's a
drier me I think this is like a cherry
Turkey tiny people it's chicken burger
thing yeah sometimes I mean I've seen
people eat it when they don't want to
eat a lot of red meat chicken mm-hmm I
think this is still me but I don't I
don't think this is one of the vegan
alternatives final answer you go say
chicken
see it's delicious yeah what is good
okay third learner oh my god smell it
smell it smell so it smells weird I feel
like all my other senses are heightened
now that I can't see this one I think
it's like a fast-food burger yes very
good okay one of these has to be vegan
but all them taste like details like me
yeah let me taste just the patty yeah I
don't know it's pretty convincing if
this is me I don't want anymore it
doesn't make me happy something about it
is just off I feel like I taste
something that feels very much like soy
sauce like something very like they're
faking ham like they're trying to make
the meat flavor without actually having
I think the texture is pretty convincing
yes but there's like an aftertaste and
that's where I'm like something's off
all I'm getting is like so much
seasoning like meat doesn't need a lot
of seasoning because you just want that
beefy beef but you know that beefy beefy
flavor but like this seems like it's
been over season like they put so much
on it to hide whatever it's pretending
to be I would say like the initial bite
is like pretty convincing we could also
be wrong but that's true I mean I think
it's vegan but I also think that this is
really yummy yeah like if I had to eat
like a meat substitute this is pretty
damn good
I'm gonna go 1/3 burger without a doubt
I'm also gonna guess burger number three
was the vegan patty the third one the
last one was a vegan burger same
absolutely the third one is the vegan
burger it looks like a burger actually
it looks phenomenal it's pretty sexy but
once you eat it once you smell it like
you just know you know vegan burgers you
can't lie to me as much as you might
look like I want you you know you're not
my type but I think vegan patty I think
of something that's like try a little
chewy but that texture was like perfect
like when you eat a meat burger that's
what it that's what it feels like
I wouldn't explicitly think that this is
better than a beef burger but like if
there comes a point where like maybe
it's like a cheaper alternative yeah I
wouldn't be opposed to eating this final
thoughts vegan stuff can be good that
one just happened to not be great yeah
it was still pretty bad there's still
pretty strong like aftertaste of my
mouth right now I love it honestly it
might have been okay without all the
onions honestly like if you didn't tell
me that one of these were vegan I would
have just eaten that thinking it was
like a normal hamburger I wouldn't have
missed anything
I definitely what is eat now yeah
[Music]